everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
keep doing some styling as you can see
we've got a lot of work to do so not
exactly the best UI sorry I was a few
minutes late I didn't realize how much
setup I would need I didn't realize my
computer had turned off and thinks it up
so just took me a few extra minutes so
let me give you a quick update you may
hear my kids in the background they're
about to leave for school so let me give
you a quick update before we start with
the coding just on what's going on so I
was recently the stir check conference
so that's in Columbus it's a tech
conference so I unexpectedly gave a talk
on react native web and I used this
project as an example I'm gonna give the
same talk next week at NDC Minnesota so
if I know anybody in Minnesota and you
want to meet up I'll be there most of
next week so let me know and one thing I
realized is when I'm using this project
to display like to demonstrate what's
going on we haven't built for for mobile
yet so I can't demonstrate that now
there is there is an issue with that so
I really want to use Expo but currently
Expo does not support the context is it
the context API or hooks what are those
two I can't remember but basically we're
doing stuff right now that is not
supported by Expo so we have to wait
until that support comes out so
we could possibly just build for react
native like built for mobile with just
regular react native and not worry about
Expo I've done that before like that's a
possibility so we may do that just
wanted to give you an update on where
I'm at was coming up and what the plans
are for this project but no matter what
today we're gonna work on styling let me
say hi to everyone and see what's up in
the chat before we get started uh Chaz
white case is why the long face no
reason I just put it they were talking
about this picture I put on the
thumbnail where I don't really look that
happy I just looked through my photos
and picked one that I hadn't used yet
and that was the first one I found so I
think I took that last week so that's
not not feeling sad today
anybody saying hello good morning
Benjamin asks how I'm doing actually not
too bad not too bad I'm uh I think I
might be coming down with something I
woke up on a sore throat and a stuffy
nose but hopefully it's nothing too bad
since how I gotta travel next week all
right
okay let me let me get started and
anybody that's asking questions in the
chat I'll get back to your questions
very soon so I'm gonna set this timer
and when this timer goes off I'm gonna
go back to the live chat and answer as
many questions as I can all right so
let's see let's get rid of X it's not
running first off let me I'm gonna go to
the contributors page just to give a
shout out to everybody that's
contributed so far so I like to put this
up here you know occasionally just to
let everybody know you know who's been
contributing so thank you to everyone
who's contributed so far definitely
welcome any any pull requests you may
have all right let's let's go to the
code first things first always start
your day off with a git pull oh looks
like okay
so I did update the gh-pages so that's
the the link and so if we go to the
project and click on this link you can
actually check out the project here so
I'm gonna put that link in the
description so you just check it out you
know right now but that's updated so I I
didn't realize that it was still running
an older version so I updated that over
the weekend and it's back to our code
okay also usually just run yarn as well
or an NPM install now I I know that
there were no pack you just pulled down
but just in case sometimes I forget
maybe I installed a package on another
computer like that way we're all set
I've already started the development
server
and so we're good to go so right now a
lot of our stuff basically our entire
app for the most part is split between
this a producer J s and app touch ass so
in terms of our Styles we can see most
of our styles are here in a pas all
right and I apologize in advance I'm
gonna yawn a lot I didn't have any
caffeine yet so it's gonna happen I'm
sorry so yeah here's our styles rate we
have it in the form of JavaScript
objects we're using the sow she'd uh
create that comes with react native okay
so let's figure out exactly what we're
gonna do we're gonna try to get done in
this stream so the last stream we did
some work with the submit button
basically we made this bigger let me go
let's shrink this down to what size 100%
size so we get a good idea when you
shrink it down to this size it does seem
like the proportions are a bit off right
but what I'd really like to do is make
these boxes look different right it's
not obvious what these even are right
now okay so ideally what I would love to
find is an SVG an open-source SVG and it
has a little icon that looks like a hero
okay and enemies so that's what I'd love
to put in here not sure if we're gonna
find that but let's just do a quick
search if we don't find anything in the
first like minute or two then we'll just
move on to something else but hopefully
we can find
things suitable for this also it might
be kind of cool to have different
backgrounds show up like I'm thinking
depending on what's going on maybe we
have different backgrounds so instead of
just a message that shows up it could be
remember this is a kids game right so we
want to try to be visual or not rely on
text-based things as much so potentially
like images or graphics would show up
for victory for defeat getting a
question right getting it wrong okay so
let's check out free SVG character icons
I don't know trying to make it the best
way to do this oh that might work
I just check out a few of these all
right that's my bad
this visit debt whoa okay all right now
but let's see how this how we would
actually go about loading this trying to
find one I like I guess it doesn't
matter let's just pick whatever because
I want to see and I see this is coming
as not an s e-g
so I don't know about that let's see if
we can drop the
yeah I'd only that'll work let me see if
everybody okay here we've got a comp saw
guys says is linked you get this like
coffee link address open what is it open
game art org that seems like exactly
what name
okay I think I've checked on here before
a long time ago for a different game now
let's see week what we can trying to see
what kind of search we can do 2d yeah if
they went to D there we go
it's
okay this might take some more searching
and figured out how to use this but I
actually really like this so I'm gonna
leave this up for now but I feel like
this is something I would want to look
at more because it seems like it has a
ton of options and this one doesn't look
like it's gonna give give us SVG's which
is what I really want basically the
reason I really want to try to find an
SVG is that we can control the size and
the color through code and we can
animate as well alright so that's that
would be like best-case scenario okay so
these are available in SVG cool alright
these ones these ones actually have
color let's just click these ones this
one first and see
eventually I do want to give the kids an
option to pick their their character so
we may want to bring in more than one of
these but let's find somebody with a
sword or something this person has this
oh it's just they're like really
specific it's not just hero character
it's actually a Spartan character all
right there we go
a knight with a sword all right let's
see that Wow you can't even get colored
versions very nice all right now here
that I want to see oh is this not free
you may have to buy these shoes
alright here we go here's another one
SVT repo comm coughs I got this in the
meantime you could just give them a
border and border radius until you find
appropriate SVG's yeah we could yeah I
just want to try whoops did I not copy
that okay this would be the last one we
try before we move on looking for like
maybe a very like cartoon looking
alright let's just grab this one just to
see what we get
it's I need to find I want to open this
with the s code so I can see what the
code looks like where is my dollars
there we go
all right so let's open this with Visual
Studio code there we are that's what I
wanted to see okay so we have an SVG all
right so let's get rid of some of this
stuff I don't want this and I'm gonna
put this right in let's find our hero
there we go
so inside our view we already have our
view for our hero I'm just gonna paste
this SVG in see now this will not work
for react native and so in this this
probably this might not even work for
what we're doing right now yes we may
have to change some of this up just even
get it to work at all expected
corresponding closing tags review what
is this I'm getting rid of all of these
and I say we should have there's our
view I love you right
something's not getting closed properly
get rid of that I'm just gonna start
getting rid of stuff that is giving us
problems I see if that fixed yep that
fixed it
okay all right let's see what happens
I'm gonna show okay John Hanson drop
some links in here I'm showing them cuz
if you put a link in the live chat it
doesn't show up by default I have to
choose to show them
okay Jonah has a link here where you
could seem like you can put an SVG file
in there and it'll clean it up so then
you can put it into the site that's cool
I usually just clean it up by hand but
that seems like it would be a lot easier
just to do it on that site so I have to
check it out let's see make sure I say
that let's see if if this is the one
anything for us here it looks like no
let's see what our air is style props
okay so our styles are messing this up
and that's just a warning though right
yeah what's the actual air check the
mapping for style properties okay so it
looks like we need to get rid of those I
was hoping it would still at least
render but
why does it say style Phil we should
just be able to say Phil all right
that's we're gonna we're gonna fix
pretty much all of these right now
okay so first thing we'll do is change
this to an equals and then add that
we'll get rid of that and all of this
okay
so that should get rid of the air with
fills and then let's try to do the same
thing with this I'm not sure if it'll
work but yeah let's just get rid of this
okay
yay haha okay it's not like we
definitely took out some stuff I think
that was needed because this does not
look like we brought in but we've got
something there okay oh nice
John also has a link for a tool to
convert SVG's into JSX so end of stuff
that react can use that's that's awesome
okay comp side guy said maybe turn their
styles into objects I thought about
doing that but then I realized that phil
is actually a valid attribute for paths
so that's why I just ended up taking
that off although this one that I just
took off here I don't know what that did
but it may have been important okay so
we have an SVG in there
I think we need to make these bigger I
know we made him smaller last time but
this is kind of like ridiculously too
small I think they need to be just a
little bigger and let's see we should
probably decide on what color scheme we
really want let's let's do this let's
see if we can find some colors like this
let's see this all right well I'm
looking at a color palette for kids
color palette 7 cool colors for kids
rooms there we go
actually that's kind of cool as long as
they can give me hex colors what no I
don't know what I don't know what that
was no was this one pinch I didn't
realize I was on Pinterest okay
all right forget that one I like those
colors but that's not gonna be and
realize I was clicking on Pinterest so
much you would think when I typed in hex
colors that would give me links that
actually have hex musting okay now I see
it says missing hex all right let's say
colors
no Ike wow this is actually really cool
it's like a lift a flat book for all the
colors so it's for kids all right I
really like that book well that's beside
the point
it's let's see use a Chrome extension it
gives you color alright I'm getting a
lot of of links for color stuff alright
let me just try out one of the I'm going
to try the last one I get
so this is going to generate colors okay
let's figure this into space for
generate color schemes click on a color
okay cool that's all alright alright
this was cool so let's spacebar get some
colors let's just wait till we find one
that looks like it's good for kids this
is nice and bright
alright let's let's pick this one no so
let's just go with this
what do y'all think oh wow I have a lot
more links - I'll have to check all
these out at some point but all right
ready what do you think about this color
palette I'll give everybody like 10
seconds to put in their opinions on this
color palette I have about two minutes
left a little over two minutes and then
I'm going to go to the chat and answer
some questions so if you have any
questions you put them in now let's cool
it looks cool all right awesome okay wow
you can do alternative shades you can do
lots of cool stuff let's see about this
exporting export palette SCSS Wow
interesting
see what this looks like you can get an
S CSS file yeah that's that might not be
a bad idea I want to open this with code
as well okay opening code cool now we
can just copy and paste these colors we
could probably put these in like an
actual theme file if we wanted to and I
believe we do have a theme so we created
a color theme like down here and this is
basically just like our background
colors but we could build out our theme
a bit more we already have it here right
so we could say hero
oops background color oh how did we do
this edition background color
trying to remember how I put this in
here I might not have done it in a way
that will work for what I wanted to do
and see okay I did do it the right way I
thought since I actually used background
color I thought for a second I was like
locked into actually using CSS but all
right let's say hero color and let's
split this so I can just grab them
all right let's yes you know color it
might
Oh my timer went off okay
when we get back from answering some
questions
we'll just finish filling this out a
little bit and then add in our colors
and then that way we'll have a pretty
easy mechanism for changing all the
colors at once and at some point we
could potentially give the user the
ability to change the theme change the
colors I think that would be kind of
cool based like me just observing my own
kids they will spend so much time like
customizing the colors and stuff that
might be cool for them like I know right
now we have it like addition subtraction
multiplication but maybe actually giving
the user the ability to further
customize the colors would with pride me
a cool feature all right so let's start
my timer over here
all right so we'll do a short break and
I'm gonna scroll up and try to answer as
many questions as I can
[Music]
Alicia or Alicia says make a code that
source students marks please using C++ I
don't really do C++ so I mean we could
do code like that but it would be like
with JavaScript and not C++ Benjamin
says I love free code camp awesome comps
I got so I was talking about building
this for like iOS or Android comps I got
says we could just use your at native
Annette yeah we actually could maybe
I'll try to do that that might be good
to try to do during a stream actually
I'd expect them to run into issues
because always do so that would be a
good one for a stream so maybe we'll try
to do that on the next stream I'd really
love to have that available before I
before next week because I want to demo
it at the conference
Sage Mode Jessie says their name is
Jessie - awesome haha I mentioned
earlier that I thought I was getting
sick imagine it says sounds like you got
the man flu been there before yeah yeah
unfortunately I have too much stuff to
do and I can't just lay around it's just
what I would normally prefer to do when
I'm safe Zack says these streams are
great by the way thank you I appreciate
that
Zack also asked if I work in Pomodoro
Technique so the 25-minute code
five-minute break I try to it's a little
bit more difficult with my my new job so
my old job I was working on things
mostly solo and I'd like stuck to the
Pomodoro Technique almost all the time
with my new job I do a lot more pair
programming and I'm in like an open
office setting so it's harder to stick
to that like the I I'm Way more likely
to just get interrupted in the middle of
it or like if I'm pair programming then
it's hard to say like I would have to
convince the other person I'm pairing
with it like this is how we're gonna do
it so I haven't found a great way to
consistently use it but I'd really like
to start using it again
sorry sage mode says beginner here need
to download Python but it's kind of
tricky don't think I'm doing it right
also I heard you don't have to download
JavaScript that's true yeah you
JavaScript just runs on the browser you
don't need to download it I don't even
remember how to download Python like if
I've done it it's been so long ago and
I'm not sure there are some like in
browser editors that will let you run
Python so you may want to check that out
it might just let you get started faster
with Python without having to mess with
the download
Benjamin says all the videos Jessie
record should be in a playlist right yep
it is in play wrists so there is a huge
playlist of all the live streams and
that's just called live coding with
Jessie and then there are other
playlists broken down by project so this
particular project which were on day 13
well has its own playlist with just like
these 13 videos a couple you are asking
how I am so I already addressed that
earlier so I'm not gonna repeat it but
you can basically am good so but you can
check out the longer answer on the
replay alright somebody who I can't
pronounce their name is some different
characters keeps asking if I am DJ smash
I am NOT DJ smash and watch me to Google
DJ smash so maybe I'll Google that after
the stream
reowww says I'm I'm not able to
understand your English I'm sorry about
that yeah I'm not sure I'll try to speak
as clearly as I can but I'm not sure
what else I could do about that I'd love
to get subtitles for these at some point
if anybody's interested in doing
subtitles you know please let me know
sigh a myth says that they unsubscribed
I'm sorry to hear that if you want to
let me know why you want subscribed I
could try to do a better job then
although they not sure they're still
stuck around if they already unsubscribe
alright let me my timer went off so
let's make a note of where I stopped
that 7:40
7:51 in my chat ok let's see what's this
okay I'm not gonna start another
Pomodoro timer we're just gonna do a
little bit more and then I'm gonna
finish up because if I do a whole nother
Pomodoro session I'm not gonna have time
to get through all the questions okay so
let me get rid of that yeah don't say
that let's just bring over these colors
a bit and see if we can get a more
reasonable color scheme okay Oh
background color let's change a
background color
do we want to go with the white
background you want to go the color
background just let me know if you if
you have an opinion on that I really
love dark themes I'm like so tempted to
just put this dark color as the
background maybe I'll just try it we'll
try it out see what happens
all right here Oh color let's go with
enemy enemy color and we'll give that
the reddish color for now and oh let's
do our button background is this yellow
that seems cool
I think the yellow actually look really
cool on the dark background button color
[Music]
okay I'm not sure what we'll do with the
green let me see if we can figure out
where that oh wait I could get we don't
have to use all the colors but yeah
we're gonna have to change the color of
the text as well so let's just put that
in there for now text color let's just
make this white for now
oops okay that's pretty cool
oops coughs I a guy mentioned I had an
extra semicolon there thank you so much
for for catching that all right so let's
shrink this side up a bit you don't
really need it and let's just try to add
in these colors and see what it looks
like so we need
the font is gonna be the hardest thing
the fun color so we need to add let's
see
you need to add an array so we need to
make our styles an array so for right
now I'm just gonna override whatever we
have with our styles here so this will
be font color and this will say there we
go active theme dot text color and it's
okay in our hero last we have Styles
hero's character let's see this even
matter
yeah we have that SVG there actually I
think the background is still showing up
so we still have some purple or on the
outside so let's do this and say
background color and active Euro color
what did I do
oops
there we go okay so what we're doing
here right is we're bringing in all the
styles that we have in our style sheet
at the bottom of character and of hero
and then we're pulling in background
colors so it'll it will cascade and like
whatever comes last will override
whatever was before it so we're already
setting the background color for our
hero I believe here but it should be
overridden by our background color here
at least that's what I think is gonna
happen all right now we have our enemies
and I can do the same very a similar
thing with our enemies background color
active themed enemy color yeah we have
more text here so we want to do style
oops
equals
four color active theme text books text
color and oh is our button
so our button color is now going to be
active theme dot button color and I
think we have another button down here
so that's
oops yeah we're not gonna be able to
copy that cuz this one's a touchable
opacity so let's make an object here and
this will be background color dots
button color nope not how it's supposed
to go active theme dot button color and
this needs to be in whoops this needs to
be an object there we go
usually a good sign that you've messed
up the syntax is when you're not getting
your autocomplete oh yeah okay we do
have some more text that needs to be
changed to the text color so fortunately
these all have the same type of thing
going on here so we're use our multiple
cursors so for the way my keyboard set
up which I don't know if this is the
default for us code or not I just press
ctrl or command D and I can do this and
get the multiple cursors right so we
need to make this an object and then
we'll make I'm sorry we need to make it
an array first and then add in a style
object what it was it font color that's
it
font color and that's going to be active
theme dot text color verify that change
for all of them yep
all right cool I'm thinking there's got
to be a better way to do this a to
because we're starting to get a lot of
stuff happening in here so we'll try to
find a better way to do it all right so
let's save that and see if it works
oh okay it works cool I'm not sure that
that actually looks better oh you know
it didn't work though this this is font
color
because it's not font color it's color I
really did somebody catch that it's just
color out of what I was thinking that's
like basic CSS right there
alright so let's find everywhere where
we have for color and change it to color
okay there we are okay this might be we
need to change it inside there but I
don't know if I'll want to change it
because I don't think that looks that
good let me know what you think maybe
it's just my screen I don't know this
does not look good to me where's our
code and just this looks like it would
look better on this screen but then when
we actually did it here not not great
yeah alright so it's saying the colors
are drab yeah it does look kind of drab
all right well the good thing is this we
now have an easy way to change all the
colors in our in our app so now if we
want to mess with new colors all we have
to do is just change these not only that
but we already set it up so that we
could easily like change themes so what
we could do is just have like four
different themes or more if we really
wanted to but for right now we're set up
for four and just flip back and forth
and really see what's which ones we like
better seam side by side we can even
open up a bunch like more than one
window at a time side by side compare
them so although we didn't find a theme
we really liked we did set it up so that
it'll be
easier to find that theme so I'm okay
with that
we also tried an SVG so probably not
gonna use this SVG but at least we have
the silhouette of a human-like form
uh-huh so let me let me go I didn't
commit this so you all can check out the
code and play what if you want if you
want to like mess with themes and stuff
and if you find a cool one and want to
do a pull request by all means please do
that but as soon as I commit this and
push it to the get repo and I go through
some questions and then finish up for
today and go to my other job this is not
really a job this is just a volunteer
for fun type of thing so the job I get
paid for I'll go to that nice all right
supposed to do a git status oops just
make this bigger yep so we modified app
dot J s get commits I'm gonna say we're
gonna add do the add together to the
commit and we're gonna put the commit
message in and let's just say oops s e-g
for hero you know do a get push all
right all that code should be there now
I can also do a deploy so that the new
code will be in that gh-pages but I
don't think I'm gonna do it yet because
I think the theme is actually uglier
than the one that's currently out there
so I'm just gonna wait before I push
that to that demo link
all right let's go to the chat and I
believe we left off yeah 751 okay
there's a lot of discussion about when
we were bringing that SVG over so I'm
going to skip some of this because we
already went over some of it all right
so see there's a lot of cool links I'm
gonna have to go through all those links
that you all shared and check them out
later on thank you for that I really
appreciate it
oh cool it looks like look good looks
good looks good great awesome
okay cool looks like a lot of you
thought it looked all right Hanzo says
hey I'm from Brazil we're watching you
awesome Thanks
Mohammad asked if I do Python I don't
really code much in Python I've done a
little bit with it years ago but not I
would not really consider myself to be
good at Python hanzo says make a
tutorial in JavaScript I do have some
tutorials videos in on my channel I
don't know if I actually have a
JavaScript for a lot of it is more like
getting all your dev environment set up
using git and things like that
fully drummer says good morning what's
going on where's the music stream the
music stream should still be going so if
you're looking for the music stream just
like get out of my stream and then I
think the music stream is usually like
always going like 24/7 so you may have
to like search for it but it should be
up still T says I don't want to
interview for a dev job too early and
lose a good opportunity with that
company because I'm not ready
when do I know I'm ready to start
applying for web developer jobs honestly
I
I think you're ready when you can
convince somebody else that you're ready
to actually have a job right like that's
that's all that really matters like if
you can convince your interviewer that
you can do the work then you'll get the
job all right so I mean to convince
yourself maybe you could do some
practice interviews and see how you do
checkout so on my youtube channel I do
have some videos on interviewing and on
my interview experience and I talk a lot
more about preparing for interviews so
there's some good resources on there she
might want to check that out I believe
there's a link to my channel in the
description of this video
lewis says are you from the netherlands
i am not familiar valence from from the
u.s Benjamin asks why it's named p7 d13
so it's project seven day thirteen looks
like that already got answered in the
chat so Thank You T says you do kind of
look like DJ smash but not really all
right I definitely have to look up this
DJ smash person after the stream
enesta says hey I like your videos thank
you appreciate that thanks for watching
red light BD says I love your tutorial
Thank You Benjamin says keep up the
excellent work made thanks man
everybody's being so nice in this dream
I actually thought I didn't do a great
job because I couldn't make anything
look nice but I I really appreciate all
the the positive encouragement that I
did yeses I'm just starting to learn
some back-end development what
technology did you do do you think I
should be learning at this stage it
really depends like it depends on what
you're using so
like if you're using node for back-end
then you definitely want to be familiar
with like node package manager like that
whole ecosystem probably Express I mean
of course like no matter what you're
doing you want to learn about version
control so most likely get how to do
stuff with with get I don't know
arguably if it's just you learning then
you might want to learn a little bit
about like actual deployment and how to
manage manage that manage servers and
stuff maybe some database stuff so it
does kind of depend exactly on what
you're working on but in general I think
those things are pretty good to know at
least a little bit about MD is Islam
luden says I love your tutorial the way
of explanation is nice oh thanks I'm
glad you liked it
dead zombie says how do you import s CSS
styles and react I see you always make
separate styles object for your
components but can I just have a
separate sass file for my components yes
you can have a sass file but got to be
careful so like for the web that will
work but if you're trying to run run
this on mobile so like we're using react
native and you can have a separate file
for your CSS or your SCS SS s CSS yeah
so that right uh-huh but you'll have to
make sure that you're only pulling those
in for web and you use the object
version of CSS for mobile hopefully that
makes sense maybe once we actually do
start running mobile at the same time
it'll make more sense but if you're just
doing like plain react and you're only
gonna build a web then yeah you can
definitely use s CSS you just have to
make sure your build pack like your your
web pack config can handle that
so depending on what you're using it
might be already available to you to
just write sass and it'll work
or you may have to set that up on your
own with webpack ernesta soon I'm going
to university to study software
engineering any tips my only advice
would be make sure you keep working on
your own side projects and keep learning
on your own with the latest stuff is in
university just the way that that things
work like it's hard for your professors
to be on the cutting edge and teach you
the latest stuff right because like they
prepare all their stuff for class in
advance so by the time they're actually
teaching it it might be outdated so
you'll learn a lot of the fundamentals
of computer science but you may not
learn what the latest tools and
techniques are so just try to keep that
up on your own comps I guess is that
would make the background color that
green color again okay so there's two
dark yeah maybe maybe dark theme is not
the right way to go for for the kids
kids app
Bartek says did anyone have such a
problem with the getup collaborators
that they could not make any commits I'm
not sure I've haven't had any issues
with that so I'm not sure what exactly
issues you're facing maybe if you could
explain a little bit more I could be
more helpful to you
fabulous is what language do you do for
your job react native mostly and also
dotnet so it's like c-sharp net core
comp saw a guy says Jessie I think your
stream is awesome
I like how you showed true development
involves a bunch of trial and error and
developers aren't super humans and we
make mistakes yeah for sure I definitely
make a lot of mistakes since I'm working
on a production production react a
little bit of react native and we make
mistakes all the time but we keep
working till we get a solo product
thanks I appreciate you saying that and
yeah that's like kind of the whole idea
behind the stream is just like this
isn't gonna be a perfect tutorial like
this is just gonna be working through
things and I don't know how I'm gonna
solve problems when I start to stream
like we figure it out together
yeah and we do make a lot of mistakes
which is exactly how it goes for me at
my real job as well
Catalans is how do you make holy water
oh and the it's the joke it's a joke
okay how do you make holy water and the
punchline is you boil the hell out of it
oh that's I thought you were serious for
a second I was gonna be like I guess you
need to find a priest
Kampai guy says this react native web
ignore the great ohio s android files
for the yarn start yes yes so actually
we we built this with create react app
and so it just runs the normal create
react tap start so it's gonna run like
react scripts start yeah and then all
those other normal files for like iOS
and Android those only get get used when
we when we build for mobile
all right I've gotten to the end of the
chat thank you all so much for watching
I'm gonna try to do another stream on
Friday I'd love to get another one in
before next week because the next week
I'll be gone so I probably won't be able
to stream maybe Friday of next week so
so keep a lookout on social media
Twitter on your notifications or
whatever on Friday morning and hopefully
I'll get another stream and then
but until then hope you have a great
great couple of days and remember if
anybody's in Minnesota and wants to hang
out let me know I'll be there next week
and yeah thanks again everybody have a
great day